Aid workers in Poland say the crisis on the
European Union's external border with Belarus
is not over yet. Poland plans to build
a wall to replace the razor-wire fence
between the two countries. Its aim is stop
illegal crossings by undocumented migrants.
But environmental campaigners say a wall will
also stop wildlife from roaming free in the area,
and could have a dire impact. DW correspondent
Jack Parrock sent us this report from that border
Residents of the ancient Białowieża forest
- this lynx, and these wolves - caught
on camera traps earlier this year.
This 600 year old forest is home to
an estimated 12 thousand species of wildlife.
Krzysztof Schmidt studies these animals - and
he says the government's plan to build a 186
kilometer wall, 5 and a half meters high,
on the country's border with Belarus will
have a devastating effect on the genetic mix.
"From the moment when the wall will be fully
constructed, then we will have two different
populations completely separated from each other.
And it will affect the future, it will affect the
sustainability of these populations because if
we divide populations into smaller and smaller
sub-populations, then the survival
is more and more vulnerable."
He warns forest is already divided for animals
by roads and intersected by multiple rail lines.
The government wants the wall to keep out asylum
seekers who were crossing the border - pushed by
the government of neighboring Belarus.
"I've been reporting on the issues
on the border for a number of months now and
this is the closest I've been able to get to
the border. Just over there, maybe 300 meters
away is the border fence. And the border guards
say that while the numbers have continued
to drop, the numbers of people crossing,
there are still attempts to break down the razor
wire fences and to get people into Poland."
Border guards intercepted 32 thousand
people in November last year - now
there's just a handful per day.
People in this area continue their
usual winter activities while the heavily guarded
exclusion zone remains in place here - authorities
check every car which nears the border.
The government says the building of the wall is
happening in consultation with wildlife experts.
"I'm aware that there are places in the national
park, the Białowieża forest, which need
special consideration. Looking at the details,
I'm sure that the border guards who are
completely responsible for building the wall,
they are tasked to build the wall with
consideration of the natural environment."
Back in the forest, Krzysztof says his institute
has provided the government with a plan
for wildlife pathways through the wall to prevent
the division of animal populations
- and hopes it will be followed.